so here on making with machine learning
i record all of my videos in english
because it's the only language that i
speak
but you guys you're from all over the
world and you speak a lot of different
languages
right now we do translated subs but i
wondered if we could use ai to do
translated dubs
i got this idea for my extremely
inspiring co-worker here at google named
marku
a couple of months ago marco filmed a
youtube video showing you how you could
create
real-time translated subtitles that
would actually be projected on your body
and even helped me build my own version
so i thought okay he did speech to text
but why not add ai text to speech
like an ai voice actor now i know a lot
of you said in the comments you hate
computer voices
but i don't mind him at all so here's
how i did it
okay this project is actually kind of
straightforward first i'll pull the
audio out of my videos and then i'll use
the speech to text api to transcribe
them
next i'll use the translation api to
convert the transcripts to any language
that i want
and then finally i'll use the text to
speech api to speak those
translated transcripts okay so the first
step is to enable some google cloud apis
for this project we'll need the speech
to text api
the text to speech api and the
translation api
i decided to do this project in python
and you can find all of my code in the
making with machine learning github repo
first i use a library called pidub to
extract the audio
from the video file and save it as a
wave next i temporarily uploaded that
file to the cloud so that it could be
used with the speech to text api
here's where i actually call the google
cloud speech to text client
there are a couple of different ways
that you can configure this api first
you specify the language code which is
what language you're transcribing from
enable automatic punctuation tells the
api to look out for punctuation like
question marks or periods
enable word time offsets gives you both
the word and the exact time the speaker
said them
diagramization config tells the api to
look out for multiple speakers
and you also have the ability to use
enhanced more accurate models for
certain languages
by the way here's an example of what the
data that actually comes out of that api
looks like
next we have to chunk the transcript
outputs that we can feed it to the
translation api
at first i thought i could do this by
splitting words into sentences
based on punctuation mark and then
translating each individual sentence
but then like a dummy i realize that
that only works for romance languages
and in japanese you can't just split
sentences by period so instead i had to
check for gaps in when the speaker
started and stopped speaking and those
were the chunks i passed to the
translation api
actually calling the translation api
only takes a couple of lines of code
here's what the results of the
translation api look like
on my transcripts finally i called the
text to speech api to speak the
translated words
you can configure the api to use
different computer voices
and you can control the speaking rate
which i use to make sure that the
computer voice sped
up or slowed down to match the rate of
the speaker in the video
sometimes i talk very fast and sometimes
i talk more slow
okay so it's about midnight right now
but i just got all of the individual
pieces of the dubber working so i'm
going to try it off for the first time
is
welcome to the no time testing center
shed we are here collecting learning and
various sports using this picture
scooter
so send the helicopter into the air and
start collecting data
there are actually two places where
errors could come from first of all the
speech to text api could make a mistake
it couldn't mishear me and mistranscribe
me
but also translation could be inaccurate
so i'm going to show you two approaches
to upping the accuracy first we can up
the quality of speech to text by using a
feature called phrase hints
here you can specify words or phrases
that you think are more likely to appear
in the video
and then the api will be more likely to
recognize them especially if they're
uncommon words or proper nouns
for translation we can use something
called a glossary which is just a csv
that specifies the way we want
certain words or phrases to be
translated for example in marcu's video
the translations for drone and tarp were
a little off
so even though marcus said tarp in
finnish the api was translating it to
shed
using glossary we can make spot fixes
like this putting these two tools
together i was able to make the accuracy
of the dubs a lot better
they're not perfect but here's what they
sound like
welcome to the ai coach testing center
tarp we are here to collect learning
data on various sports using this image
scooter so send the drone into the air
and start collecting data
let's listen to a few other examples
i have to make a new year's resolution
to eat less treats and play more sports
there have been companies non-profit
organizations and educational institutes
so i always thought it would make sense
to stick to something simpler
like software engineering
what do you think would you watch one of
these ai dub videos let me know in the
comments below and i'll see you next
time